[Music]
straight ahead on Long crime daily I
don't want to be the Sandy Hook man okay
it was a very small part of whatever
covered and dead and I followed a lot of
this stuff being reported by 4chan that
tries to be wrong I believe the children
died I've said that over and over again
defendant Alex Jones shows up for court
then leaves minutes later as the Sandy
Hook defamation trial moves into its
second week plus
[Applause]
[Music]
what could be next for an odd Syed now
that a judge has vacated his conviction
after more than 20 years in prison for
the alleged murder of his girlfriend and
several updates in the tangled web of
cleotha abstin a man accused of killing
Memphis teacher Eliza Fletcher and
charge in his second attack now the
defendant's mother is speaking out for
the first time then later the Pike
County Massacre trial of George Wagner
IV you were considering either something
that muffled the gun or possibly that
they had been drugged such that they
would not responding would not wake up
that's correct jurors here from the
forensic pathologist who performed
victims autopsies Vaughn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer The Alex Jones
defamation trial stretches now into its
second week in Connecticut with
testimony from a social media analyst
giving insight to the effects of false
content online over time the case filed
against Jones comes after he claimed
that the 2012 Sandy Hook school shooting
was a hoax put on by crisis actors to
push gun control the plaintiffs in the
Connecticut case are made up of family
members of Aid of the students and staff
killed plus an FBI agent a total of 15
plaintiffs overall they say Jones's
followers have harassed them and even
made death threats in the wake of his
comments Jones has already been found
liable for the damages in this case
meaning jurors would decide how much
drones should pay out he was already
ordered to pay 49.3 million dollars in a
separate defamation case out of Texas
media Outlets caught up with Jones as he
arrived to the courthouse Tuesday and
again as he subsequently left moments
later when he learned he would not be
testifying just yet
I'm here to testify I'm here to do what
needs to be done this is now will be the
second time they've changed when they
say they said they'll let us know later
when or if they want us here so you're
not testifying today no I'm not
testifying today I'm obviously gonna
have to sit until the trial is over
because they keep jerking me around that
and that's fine
you just said I'm here to testify and
I'm here to tell the truth and I told
the truth I apologize on Joe Rogan four
years ago episode 1255 for 30 minutes
before I was ever sued I don't want to
be the Sandy Hook man okay it was a very
small part of whatever covered and did
and I followed a lot of stuff being
reported by 4chan they're trying to be
wrong I believe the children died I've
said that over and over again I've been
apologizing for six years four years ago
on Joe Rogan three years ago on Stephen
Crowder there's hundreds of apologies
but now when I go on shows they say do
you want to apologize I go no
I've apologized over 100 times I'm not
the guy that started questioning Sandy
Hook I did for a while believe it might
have been staged I thought Jesse
Smollett was staged turned out I was
right I thought wmd's and Iraq were
staged turned out I was right but I did
not premeditatedly create this whole
story to quote make money it's hurt me
over the last 10 years
once testimony did get underway social
media analyst Clint Watts took the stand
to talk about how he was asked to
consider what effects of false
information there could be on Jones's
audience and how it might change their
perception of reality
and when you are uh when are using these
these uh emotions fear anger
demonization against a Target do you
have experience does that expose the
target to increased risk of harm it does
if they if they have used information to
change people's beliefs or perceptions
it will leave them at times to pursue of
harms against a Target and have you
observed and uh examined how these types
of narratives lead to harassment uh in
an online community absolutely it the
the range is everything from uh you know
harms against children uh it can be
involved in terms of criminal activity
mobilizing people to Target an
individual under false pretenses I I
think the one over the consistently
through my career is extremists meaning
that terrorist groups use this sort of
information manipulation and make people
angry to pursue things as a Target
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney Bernardo villalona and co-host
Terry Austin Bernard Jones was in full
form outside the courthouse could what
he does outside the court add more
dollars to how much he must pay in the
court
absolutely whatever Alex Jones says out
in your street and the public can be
used against him when he testifies
before this jury can be confronted with
all his statements and all his
statements all seem as he's coming off
very harsh very strong very in terms of
that he is fulfilling this lie and still
believes this lie despite him saying oh
I apologize but you're doing that
because you know there's a trial going
on he is feeding into his base this is
who he is all right now Terry what was
your impression of while it's on the
stand or standing uh kind of in the
courtroom do you think the jury
understood his message overall well you
know it was a complicated message but I
think he was excellent delivering that
message he basically is extremely Highly
Educated he went to West Point he was
trained at Quantico he was in the
military he was an FBI agent and he
clarified what his analytic process was
he talked about the four M's the message
the messenger the medium and the method
and I thought he did an excellent job
talking about how Alex Jones and
Infowars made sure they did all of that
they based everything in fear they
created the audience they used different
mediums like social media they had an
infrastructure so I think that he was
very good I will say however that I
think the defense attorney was having
difficulty formulated his questions and
he kept having to rephrase and that can
be a little bit annoying to the jury and
perhaps the witness didn't come across
as well because of that all right we'll
see how the Jerry content plays
defamation charges and fines after this
more testimony in this case and Broadway
star and TV actress Laura Austin is has
filed a lawsuit against the New York
Post for defamation over an article
published a year ago Austin says
claiming the newspaper lied causing harm
to her reputation both professionally
and personally and that their actions
cause emotional distress the article at
the center of the suit claims
awesomeness was fired from a special
performance of a planned Revival of the
musical crazy for you for refusing to
get a covid-19 vaccination days after
the article was published Austin has
posted a statement to social media
saying she had withdrawn from the
production not that she had been fired
Austin took to social media to express
her opinions over vaccine mandates and
says she would back out of the
production because she hadn't been
vaccinated the actress was also replaced
in a London production of Bonnie and
Clyde Austin is seeking at least five
million dollars in Damages
still ahead on Law and crying daily at
cleotha abstin's mother speaks out after
her son faces several charges in the
attack of one woman and in the murder of
Memphis teacher Eliza Fletcher but first
for the next steps for the newly
released defendant Anand Syed after the
vacating of the 2000 murder conviction
[Music]
welcome back Maryland officials now have
30 days to decide whether they will
fully drop charges against Anan Syed the
man whose 2000 conviction for the
alleged murder of his girlfriend was
overturned late Monday afternoon once I
had left the courthouse he was met with
cheers then officials held a press
conference after the decision was
announced
my office petitioned the court jointly
with Erica Suter from the office of the
public defender
and asked that Adnan Syed be given a new
trial where he is adequately represented
and the latest evidence presented in the
interests of fairness and Justice which
is and has always been the Hallmark of
my Administration as State's attorney
for Baltimore City at this stage a trial
has been set set in for a new trial date
because we're not yet declaring not yet
declaring Adnan Syed is Innocent but we
are declaring that in the interest of
fairness and Justice he is entitled to a
new trial
adnan's hands case Rose to Fame in 2014
when the podcast cereal broke listening
records the investigative series cast
out on his 2000 conviction for the
murder of his high school girlfriend 18
year old Heyman Lee he was been behind
bars since his 1999 arrest and since
then Zion has maintained his innocence
Terry unreliable phone cell cell phone
tracking alternative suspects and a
shoddy investigation what piece of
evidence gives you if any doubt that
Sayed got a fair trial you know what
Brian based on all of that evidence in
my mind there's no doubt that Saeed did
not get a fair trial and as you well
know as a defense attorney under the
Sixth Amendment every defendant is
entitled to one a speedy trial competent
Council and impartial jury he has to
know what his accusations are against
him he has to know the nature of the
charges but the most important thing
here in this case the evidence against
you and there was exculpatory evidence
against him that he did not get an
opportunity to pursue and that included
as you said the existence of alternative
suspects that could have made a huge
difference in this case it won't bring
back the decades he spent in jail but it
would vindicate him if he gets an
opportunity to have another trial or if
the prosecution decides not to bring
another trial at all yeah not just that
he didn't get it but also the jury
didn't hear either deciding guilt or not
not guilty Bernardo the clock is ticking
as the prosecution has 30 days to decide
if they will retry his head so what are
the next steps for both the prosecution
and defense
so the next steps for the prosecution in
that be States Attorney Marilyn Mosby
who's heading up this office is for them
to determine number one does Marilyn
Monsey both be believe in the guilt of
Mrs Syed and number two do you have
enough evidence credible evidence to
prove this case Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt because we know from The Trial
there are huge issues in terms of
credibility so I'm not sure that they
will have enough in order to retry Mr
said if in fact they believe that he is
guilty and that a jury shall listen to
this case but the biggest Injustice is
just how Tyree said look you had
exculpatory evidence and that was not
turned over being a prosecutor is about
pursuing Justice not merely conviction
and this was a huge travesty for the
criminal justice system for those prior
prosecutors to have held on to
exculpatory evidence Absolutely I'll
leave it at that because he Bernard you
said it perfectly switching to Ohio
where a physical confrontation during a
traffic stop turns violent between a man
and a female cop then several Good
Samaritans stopped to help and it all is
caught on camera take a look
hello
monster I will be placed on it is why
I'm stopping you the speed 57 and a
35. why are you getting out of the car
sir
I don't need my driver's license
12 radio this meal just stepped out of
the vehicle
step over here now
see it on the ground
have a seat I'm not sitting I got shit
back off back oh no shit mother
put your hands behind your back I will
tase you sir
knock knock
shut up
you don't do that to a woman
stand me
64 year old David kubek is facing
several charges including assaulting a
police officer speeding and driving
without a seat belt coming up on Law and
crime daily on Memphis man's second
accuser is speaking out against police
after it took a year and a murder to
charge cleophan abstin with the assault
plus the forensic Pathologists who
performed the autopsies in the Pike
County Massacre caves takes a stand in
the trial of George Wagner IV
thank you
[Music]
welcome back district attorneys in Las
Vegas Nevada are seeking to remove Clark
County public administrator Robert tell
us from office after the politician's
arrest on murder charges tell us
allegedly it killed prize-winning
investigative reporter Jeff German on
the Las Vegas Review Journal earlier
this month German known for his
hard-hitting investigations of
government corruption and the mob had
recently published a series of
investigative reports on Telus accusing
the official of abusing the resources of
his office bullying staff and having an
inappropriate relationship with a female
staffer even though he's married
Telus lost his bid for re-election
following the newspaper expose
investigators say tell us was seen on
surveillance video at German's home the
next day he was found stabbed to death
the defendant appeared in court Tuesday
morning for a brief hearing his attorney
was excused and replaced and he was
ordered to be held without bail Telus is
scheduled to return to court for
preliminary hearing October 26th
and in Tennessee the alleged first
victim and the now defendant's mother
are speaking out in the case of Cleo
abstin as a 38 year old faces a slew of
charges including rape and murder absent
was arrested earlier this month after
Memphis teacher Eliza Fletcher went
missing while out on an early morning
jog Weeks Later abstin was charged in a
second attack which happened in
September of 2021. Alicia Franklin broke
her silence this week identifying
herself as the victim in that case she
says absent blindfolded her held a gun
to her neck took her into an abandoned
Apartment and raped her though she says
at the time Memphis Police dropped the
ball in her case not processing her rape
kit for 11 months now absent's mother is
also speaking out for the first time
since her son was arrested for murder
insisting abstin is innocent Virgie
abstin claims her son is being quote
railroaded for a violent crime absent
was due to appear in court Monday but
the hearing was rescheduled for
September 28th
Terry Alicia Franklin is speaking out
against the police basically saying if
they didn't dismiss her a future attack
may not have happened do you sense any
civil rights claims against the Memphis
Police by either victim's family
well it is possible that both victims
could potentially pursue some civil
rights claims Alicia Franklin as you
mentioned she had that rape kit that
wasn't properly analyzed and Eliza
Fletcher her death it might have been
prevented and you can bring a civil
rights action under section 1983 of the
Civil Rights Act if the wrongdoer was
acting under color of law or legal
Authority so they could potentially
bring a claim for failure to you know
have equal protection or due process
under the 14th Amendment I think it will
be difficult though because I think
there might be a qualified immunity here
that they could certainly argue in
defense of that claim agreed Bernardo
Bernardo there seems to be a lot of
lessons to be learned here by many
attached to these two cases assuming
clotha is found guilty what else means
to change to ensure multiple abductions
by the same man doesn't happen again
well I think what needs to be changed is
that there has to be some kind of
database that's kind of worldwide or
actually around the country so that way
different police stations can be able to
look at common threads that are going on
in different counties so they can be on
the lookout and also give notice to
other counties in terms of look I have
something that was similar that happened
here so you need to take this into
account because possibly this can be
taking place in your county yeah I like
the idea we've got to somehow work
better together to protect Each Other
Well when we come back jurors hear
testimony from the forensic pathologist
who conducted all eight autopsies in the
Pike County Massacre as George Wagner
the four stands trial for his part in
the murders of the rodent and Gilly
families
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily jurors
in Ohio here at detailed testimony about
the entries the Rodin and Gilly families
suffered in the Pike County Massacre
case as George Wagner IV stands trial
for his role in The Murders eight
members of the rodent and Gilly families
were shot to death in their homes in
April of 2016. most of them were in
their beds investigators initially
thought the killings could be drug
related but later determined the murders
came amid a custody dispute involving a
young child George's Brothers shared
with Hannah Rhoden George his brother
Jacob and their parents were later
charged with murder Jake and their
mother Angela pled guilty to the charges
they are expected to testify against
George testimony Tuesday began with
forensic pathologist Dr Karen Lohman
with the Hamilton County coroner's
office who testified about the victim's
injuries she told the jury about what
stood out to her as she began performing
the autopsies
it it became apparent looking at where
the wounds were that it it seemed that
many of them
were shot multiple times and never moved
never appeared to have reacted to other
people in the house being shot as well
and so in my mind I was trying to figure
out why somebody wouldn't respond when
other people in the house are getting
shot I think they would wake up with
gunfire
so one of the things I did was
did a little bit of extra toxicology to
see if maybe they'd been drugged and
they were all didn't wake up because
they were sleeping
um
and another thought was um
well mostly it was the drugs I was
concerned about that maybe they had
drugs the other thought though was that
maybe there was something that was
muffling the gunfire
um but
um
I I can't find evidence on the body that
would suggest that there's something
that was muffling the the fire that's
not something I could see
how do you think Dr Lohman testified was
it uh dry silent science sorry of a
victim's final moments or did it paint
the picture of the brutality of their
deaths
well so yeah took the money from the
coroner medical examiner depending on
the state uh they have different names
it's very intriguing and intriguing why
because it shows you the heineness of
the actions of the shooter of the killer
of how much how many times that each of
these victims were actually killed and
that there were no defensive wounds that
they didn't even expected so the
testimony of a coroner or medical
examiner can give you a lot of
information that despite that person not
being alive being able to testify the
body speaks volumes yeah now Terry the
corner is testimony seemed pretty
straightforward do you think the defense
can or did poke any holes in her
testimony on cross-examination
well I think if I had been the defense I
would not question that corner at all
there were not many discrepancies in her
testimony if any for instance she talked
about a computerized chain of custody so
there's no question about contamination
she's well educated so there's no
question about her qualifications but I
suppose one of the areas the defense
could pursue would be the fact that this
coroner herself was the one who examined
all eight individuals she did all eight
autopsies and I suppose you could
question would not it be more efficient
if you spread out the work you could get
to the body sooner but there's no
evidence that there was any delay that
would have caused a different result so
I don't think there's any holes here
absolutely probably don't cross examine
her like you said well thank you for
joining us here on lawn crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]